STEPHANIE R. WONG:
Cloud Functions 2nd gen
helps developers achieve more
when deploying their code
to a serverless environment.
Longer processing times,
faster response times
with greater cost efficiency,
and native integrations
with dozens of event sources.
Features like these
enable developers
to take advantage of serverless
with more diverse workloads.
I introduced some of this
new functionality embedded
into the new generation
of Cloud Functions.
But today, let's
take a deeper dive
into how these
functions in 2nd gen
work and walk through how
developers can take advantage
of this functionality.
These new features in
Cloud Function 2nd gen
can be categorized into two
key themes, enhanced underlying
infrastructure and greater
event integrations based
on the open source
spec CloudEvents,
all while maintaining
the same developer
contract you're familiar
with in Cloud Functions.
Write your code, deploy it,
and let the serverless platform
handle the rest.
It is worth sharing what powers
the improved infrastructure
of this new generation.
2nd gen leverages Cloud
Run under the hood,
which is Google's container
as a service platform.
This is where new
2nd gen functionality
such as concurrency and
traffic splitting comes from.
The beauty of it is that you
don't have to build and bring
a container image to
Cloud Function 2nd gen
as your ticket for admission,
just to use a new feature set.
Cloud Functions 2nd gen
maintains the same developer
experience as its
preceding generation.
Just bring your code and
the serverless platform
will handle the rest.
All right, let's now dig
into how these features
work, starting with
one of the ones
we heard developers ask
for the most, running
functions with a lot
longer execution times.
Event-driven functions can
now run an additional minute
compared to the
previous generation,
and HTTP functions can
run more than six times
longer in second generation.
This means that you can now
bring more complex functions
that perform more intensive
processing to Cloud Functions.
To demonstrate, we'll run this
function using Cloud Functions
Python 3.8 runtime.
It may not be complex, but it'll
run for the maximum timeout.
It's important to
note that the max
timeout is supported across
all language runtimes, not just
Python.
We'll deploy this code
as a function called
function-timeout and invoke it.
With the function invoked, we
can see the logs from our code
directly in the Cloud
Functions console.
The function counts
down minute by minute
until it returns a 504 once
the timeout has been hit.
We can also view execution times
for our long-running functions
in dashboards provided
by Cloud Functions.
And if we look at how we
configure this max timeout,
we can do this by appending
the timeout parameter
at deploy time to override the
default timeout of one minute.
Now let's briefly talk about
the greater amount of resources
that are now available to
your functions in 2nd gen.
Previously you were only able
to specify how much memory you
wanted to make available
to your instances
up to roughly 8 gigabytes, with
only up to 2 CPUs per function
instance.
Now you're able to specify
double the amount of CPUs,
up to 4 vCPUs to
allocate to your function
while also doubling the
amount of memory you can make
available, up to 16 gigabytes.
This can help
resource-intensive workloads
that need to
process large files,
write to an in-memory
file system,
or even perform
parallel processing.
Let's move on to
traffic-splitting.
In second generation, Cloud
Functions as a platform
provides for you automatic
traffic splitting
between various
revisions of your code.
With this functionality,
you can feel safer
rolling out new
versions of your code,
knowing 2nd gen
can make patterns
like canary deployments
or A/B testing
straightforward to implement.
Take this example
in the diagram where
we have a new version of our
code that we have deployed.
Rather than
immediately promoting
it to serve all
production traffic,
we can gradually begin sending
traffic to it using 2nd gen,
starting with 10%.
Let's simulate the scenario
by actually deploying
a simple HTTP function.
There may be a case
in which we are
using Cloud Function support
for environment variables
to flip a new feature
in our code on or off.
But in this example, let's
just set the variable version
to 1.0.0.
To deploy the next
version of the code,
we supply the new
environment variable
value to reflect that we
are deploying version 2.0.0.
Once we have both versions
of the code deployed
to Cloud Functions,
we can actually
see that each revision
we've deployed
is being tracked in the
underlying infrastructure,
Cloud Run.
Now that Cloud Run has shared
with us the unique revision
IDs for our two versions
of our function,
we can now declaratively
define how traffic
should flow to each revision.
In our case here, we want
to send 90% of traffic
to the first version and 10% of
traffic to the second version.
We do so by providing
a single parameter
to the underlying
Cloud Run service,
backing the Cloud Function
with those traffic percentages.
Once we begin issuing requests
to the function's URL,
we can see that we get
a simple response that
shows what version of
the app we are accessing.
The majority of our traffic
is routed to version 1,
and a small minority of our
traffic is routed to version 2,
all configured by
simple gcloud commands.
Speaking of functions
handling requests,
let's cover one
more feature that
comes from the new underlying
infrastructure in 2nd gen,
concurrency.
Previously in Cloud Functions,
each instance of your code
would handle a single request.
This means that as
more requests come in,
the more compute time
your function uses.
In Cloud Functions 2nd
gen, however, you're
now able to define
concurrency, that is,
having one instance of your
code handle multiple requests
at the same time.
Let's deploy a simple
Python 3.8 function.
Once we've deployed
this function,
we can then utilize the
underlying Cloud Run
functionality and update
that Cloud Function to handle
more than one concurrent
request at a time, which
is the default. In this case,
we'll set this value to 8.
We can then use the hey
utility to demonstrate
how Cloud Functions
will handle concurrency.
We'll send 8 requests at once
from 8 different workers.
In our demo, our Cloud
Function only accepts requests
from authenticated users, so we
will obtain our identity token
to pass in our
requests using gcloud.
And finally, we'll
send the request
to the URL provided to
us by Cloud Functions.
The code for this function
simply sleeps for 15 seconds.
You'll see we deploy the two
revisions, the more recent with
concurrency at 8,
and the one before it
with concurrency at 1.
When we hit the function
with concurrency at 1,
we see 1 request respond
quickly and the remaining 7
take much longer.
This is because we only had one
warm instance of our function.
Every other request required
a new instance of our function
to spin up, which takes time.
However, after updating
concurrency to 8,
we see that all our
requests complete roughly
within the expected 15 seconds.
This is because we had one warm
instance, that could handle
all 8 requests simultaneously.
This brings up a
pattern with which you
can utilize concurrency with.
In both first and
second generation,
you have the ability to
define a minimum number
of warm instances that are
always ready to handle requests
to your function.
This allows for lower latency
responses from your function,
since you don't need
to pay the penalty
from having your code start up.
Now pair this with concurrency.
Because a function instance can
handle more than one request
at a time, you can now actually
use concurrency combined
with minimum instances.
This helps you reduce the
amount of min instances
you may need to keep
around, while still ensuring
that you can serve a
certain amount of requests
with lower latency.
Note that, in the example
we evaluated prior,
all we have to do is add the
min instances parameter when
deploying the Cloud Function.
Cloud Function 2nd
gen can support up
to 1,000 concurrent requests.
But this maximum for
concurrent requests
varies by language
runtime, so it's
advised that you review
the documentation depending
on what language you want
to use with Cloud Functions.
Last but not least, let's
talk about the new eventing
model in Cloud Functions
second generation.
The previous generation
of Cloud Functions
had a smaller set
of events that could
trigger your code's execution,
and these were fairly limited.
If you wanted to trigger
your code outside of the set,
you typically had to wire
code to publish events
to Cloud Pub/Sub.
By integrating with
Eventarc, we ensure
that every event that
triggers your code
adheres to the CloudEvent
specification, an open standard
for event data format.
This means that your
code can consistently
handle events in
the same format,
regardless of what
the source is.
With these Eventarc
integrations,
over 90-plus event
sources using Cloud
audit logs can now
be natively created
as triggers for
event-driven functions.
No custom code that you
need to wire together
just to trigger your code
with Google Cloud events.
Of course, you still can utilize
some custom event sources
with Pub/Sub to
trigger your functions.
In this demonstration
here, we are
using the second generation
triggers based on Eventarc
and audit logs to
process BigQuery event
data every time a query is run.
We'll use a query
in BigQuery now.
This one will roughly
query 4.5 terabytes of data
and take less than 30
seconds to complete.
This is a fairly
large query, so we
might want to use a
Cloud Function to react
to its currents, maybe use
something like Notify Admins
that it ran.
With the query finished, we can
get back to our Cloud Function
and see that we are writing
out the query information
to standard out.
But of course, we
could extend this
to send a message to Slack, do
some processing, or anything
else that we can imagine.
BigQuery is just one example.
With Cloud audit
logs and Eventarc,
we can now trigger
off dozens and dozens
of Google Cloud events.
With all of these new features
within these two themes,
Cloud Functions second
generation considerably
improves the experience
for developers when
compared to its
preceding version.
But for all of
you who have built
atop of the first
generation, it's
important to note your function
in the first generation
will continue to run as is.
Over time, if you find the
features suit your needs
or improve your
workflow, you can
begin to deploy these functions
to the second generation.
So thanks for spending this time
digging into Cloud Functions
2nd gen. If you
want to learn more,
then check out the
documentation and code labs
to get familiar with the
improved developer experience.
This is Stephanie Wong.
See you next time.